so bernie you look tan rested and ready
um
they always look better when they get
off the campaign trail it must be
grueling campaigning but look you made a
speech yesterday
and uh you know it was about what we do
when trump says he's not leaving and
um i imagine this is a speech you never
thought you would have to make
bill i mean that's absolutely true i
mean this country today faces enormous
problems
we have massive income and wealth
inequality we're the only major country
not to guarantee
health care to all you got millions of
people working for starvation wages we
got climate change
we got systemic racism we got a whole
host of problems
never in a million years that i ever
think that i would have to give a speech
about what do we do if a president
refuses to lose office
leave office if he loses i never never
thought that i would have to give that
speech or anybody else
but that is where we are today and i i
would simply say
bill and i know you have made this point
many many times
listen to what trump is saying
don't brush it off don't say oh this
guy's crazy he'll say this
you know any any other day listen to
what he is saying
and what he is saying over and over
again
is quote the only way that we
i.e trump can lose the election is if it
is rigged end of quote in other words
if we win that's great and if we lose we
really didn't lose
because it's rigged you all know mail-in
ballots
are very dangerous they're a hoax
they're a scam
so we cannot lose this election and
obviously
we're not leaving office but i i've been
i mean i asked you this question in
april i've been asking this of democrats
for for years
and and they pretty much just laughed it
off you said in april
i asked you what what what what do we do
you said well you mobilize the american
people
in a way that they've never been
mobilized before to remind the president
whether he likes it or not we live in a
democracy
he said i think we have to make it clear
that if he loses the election he'll be
out of office and replaced by the new
president
i don't hear a plan there i just hear a
wish we wish that would happen
i still don't know what the plan is
well you know the bottom line is there
are things that we have to do now
to make sure that biden wins and if
trump
attempts to stay in office after losing
there will be a number of plans out
there
to make sure that he is evicted from
office what but right now in the next
five weeks our job is to defeat
him and defeat him badly
you